For the flip the page,
The musk of old paper, the newsprint on our fingers.
This is why we love comics.
From the morning commute, to late nights by flashlight, and sneaking them in class.
Because to grandpa, they're The Funnies. To Dad, they're comic books. To us, they're graphic novels.
This is why we love comics.
For Sunday mornings, and New Comics Day, for your pull list and your RSS feed.
for spinner racks, and long boxes, for bags and boards.
and an extra room to store them all.
This is why we love comics.
For superheros, anti-heros, and everyday heros, for the mainstream independent an underground,
Because we're first in line when Hollywood gets them right,
And first online when they get them wrong.
This is why we love comics.
For late-night inking, for xeroxing and stapling, and calling ourselves publishers.
For Stan and for Jack, and Alan and Neil,
For Maggy and Colleen, and Jerry and Mike. This is why we love comics.
For the aisles of Comic-Con, or local hotel ballroom,
For spending months making a costume we'll wear for only one day.
This is why we love comics.
Because Charlie Brown taught us how to read.
Batman taught us how to draw, and Superman taught us how to be brave.
This is why we love comics.
Because with only four colors, some pictures and words, they can make us laugh, make us think, transport us to other worlds,
and make us feel closer to home. For millions the reasons - and the flip but that next page.
This is why we love comics.